et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
olivier dussopt bonjour bon merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous il est délégué
chargé des comptes publics on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes point des
interviews en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
pascal jalabert bonjour pascal du groupe
les bras les journaux régionaux de l'est
de la france on commence par quelques
questions d'actualité avant de parler
longuement de la dette et du déficit
mais d'abord cette traque des heures de
traque
en dordogne pour rechercher un ancien
militaire condamné à plusieurs reprises
pour violences conjugales il s'est
introduit au domicile de son ex compagne
malgré un bracelet électronique après
les féminicides hayange et de mérignac
est ce qui a clairement des failles dans
le suivi des auteurs de violences
conjugales
je n'ai pas pour habitude de m'exprimer
sur une affaire en cours ce n'est pas ma
responsabilité ce n'est pas mon
périmètre ministériel
la première chose que je veux dire c'est
d'abord le soutien le plein soutien à
toutes les forces de sécurité qui sont
mobilisées en formant le souhait qu est
le voeu que cet individu puisse être
très rapidement arrêté et est ainsi mis
hors d'état de nuire
c'est aussi une pensée de compassion et
de soutien d'une policière municipale a
été grièvement blessé il ya quelques
jours
vous l'avez rappelé des femmes sont
décédées sous les coups de leur ex
conjoint est à elles et à leurs proches
qu'il faut qu'il faut penser
nous renforçons les moyens nous l'avons
dit et moyens la police la justice et
nous devons toujours faire mieux en la
matière malheureusement tant qu'il y
aura un fait tant qu'il y aura un
féminicide tant qu'il y aura une
violence il y aura du travail
je pense qu'il faut à la fois continuer
à renforcer tour est encore renforcée
avec la plus grande
comment dire le plan d'objectivité et le
plus grand la plus grande distance
possible non pas pour être insensible
simplement pour ne jamais sombrer dans
une forme de dérive au de récupération
est justement un mot sur cette police
hermine donc ça loire atlantique à une
policière municipale est attaqué par pas
par une par une personne radicaliser
déséquilibre on sait pas trop comment
faut-il protéger ces policiers faut que
les armes et systématiquement si bien
les différents articles et différents
comptes rendus la policière municipale
qui on souhaite évidemment le le plus
prompt et le meilleur des
rétablissements semblent être armés
puisque j'ai cru dire que l'assaillant
était parti avec son arme cela montre
que toutes les réponses ne sont pas dans
l'armement
il ya de la formation ou la renforçons
aussi et puis au delà il faut faire en
sorte que point par point
étape par étape nous puissions toujours
mieux les protéger mais je le répète le
ministre de l'intérieur de mise la
justice font un travail formidable
nous les accompagnons nous leur donnons
les moyens je crois nécessaire pour
faire monter en puissance lors
différents services ou leurs différentes
forces et les réponses à apporter
dire que tout soit ou peut-être résolu
en l'espace de quelques heures n'est
jamais vrai travail de longue haleine et
ça ce travail de longue haleine qu'il
faut se consacre l on va parler de votre
périmètre ministériel ya beaucoup de
choses à dire sur la dette le déficit le
budget d'abord vous avez annoncé ce week
end une aggravation du déficit public à
220 milliards c'est un record c'est 47
milliards ses déficits de l'état
déficit budgétaire de l'état et ses 47
milliards de plus que prévu
oui pour seulement comment vous
expliquer cette différence pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que en
2020 nous avions prévu des moyens pour
répondre à la crise et l'impact de la
crise a été moins difficile moins grave
que prévu il a été majeur la récession
est à 8% c'est absolument historique
mais les prévisions que nous avions
faites notamment au mois de juillet au
mois de septembre et est encore plus
négative et donc nous avions été très
présent avec bruno le maire en
inscrivant plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros de dette d'urgence une
partie de ces aides n'ont pas été
consommés autour de 29 milliards d'euros
nous les avons reporté sur l'année 2021
et à l'occasion de cette loi de finances
rectificative que nous présenterons
mercredi matin en conseil des ministres
nous intégrons ses 29 milliards d'euros
de dépenses dans le budget 2021 est par
ailleurs le président de la république a
pris un engagement
le premier ministre a détaillé de
manière extrêmement précise et qui
consiste à dire que nous n'arrêtons pas
les aides du jour au lendemain la
reprise économique la reprise d'activité
de déconfinement tout ça s'est fait de
manière progressive et nous ferons en
sorte que l'extinction des aides
d'urgence qui est la règle lorsque la
crise se termine il faut que les aides
d'urgence s'éteignent et c'est
extinction soit très progressif
fonctionnalités par exemple reste
totalement vigueur pour l'activité du
mois de mai et va être dégressif avec
une prise en compte des pertes de
chiffre d'affaires au cours des mois de
juin et de juillet d'août pour
l'activité partielle
nous allons progressivement réintroduire
un reste à charge pour les employeurs et
nous allons faire
aussi sur quatre mois avec une montée
progressive et je précise que pour les
secteurs les plus touchés
l'événementiel la restauration des cafés
hôtels restaurants
nous allons différencier distinguer les
calendriers et faire en sorte que des
secteurs qu'on appelle protéger les
fameux secteur et 100 et 102 bis
maintenant entrés dans le langage
presque courant soit protégé plus
longtemps et en tous cas de manière
différenciée au mans star à présent sur
cnn cela représente 15 milliards d'euros
soit 16 sur cmt sur dirigé rectificatif
mais du coup on vous assumez en de
creuser le déficit il va être de 9 4% du
df prévu en loi de finances initiale
c'est ce qu'a annoncé bruno le maire la
dette avait de combien de la dette va
s'établir autour de 110 à 2,2 pour cent
soit légèrement plus que ce que nous
avions prévu
tout ça ce sont des chiffres à l'instant
nous parlons qui tient compte à la fois
airport crédit que j'ai évoqué des 15
milliards d'euros que nous ajoutons pour
permettre de financer la sortie
dégressive des aides
le fonds solidarité des exonérations de
cotisations lui l'activité partielle ça
tient compte aussi prévisions de
croissance nous avons revu notre
prévision il ya quelques semaines pour
tenir compte du fait du quasi
confinement du mois d'avril avec une
croissance à 5 % et donc au fil de vos
maintenait que tu que nous maintenons
bien bien évidemment c'est réaliste de
maintenir une croissance assez prudent
et réaliste
beaucoup nous disait vous êtes un peu
près dans vous êtes un peu pessimiste
nous avons vu au début de l'année que la
reprise est là le rebond est possible il
est même très possiblement très fort
mais il y à ici ou là quelques
fragilités les entreprises du bâtiment
peinent à s'approvisionner en matières
premières parce que la reprise est
mondiale ça peut aussi être un motif de
fragilité mais nous avons suffisamment
d'indicateurs pour penser que cette
prévision de 5 % et est atteignable et
nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour
l'atteindre notamment avec le
déploiement du plan de relance cette
dette qui est supérieur donc un autre
richesse nationale puisque neige
annoncées 117% comment l'art en bourse
et est ce qu'au fond on ne va pas
devenir perpétuel avec du temps avec du
temps parce que effectivement la dette
est importante
nous bénéficions si je puis dire d'un
contexte qui fait que les emprunts que
nous avons dû faire en 2020 2021 est il
en train de te faisant en 2021 en 2020
et 2021 nous lisons à des taux qui sont
des taux extrêmement bas s'ils ont été
négatifs sont légèrement positif mais
ils nous permettent de faire face
la france pas toujours tenu ses
engagements et et nous continuerons à
les tenir
à honorer nos engagements à honorer nos
créanciers nous allons prendre du temps
nous allons aussi amélioré et est portée
soutenir la croissance c'est l'objet du
plan de relance
selongey de tous les soutiens
l'investissement que nous faisons c'est
notamment l'objet de tout ce que nous
faisons dans le domaine industriel avec
un objectif qui est de générer de la
croissance et donc des recettes pour
faire face à nos engagements est un
engagement qui est de ne pas augmenter
les impôts et on à revenir juste sur le
remboursement de la dette mais d'abord
on va rester sur les dépenses et ce
budget rectificatif que vous présentez
donc mardi en conseil des ministres il
ya 15 milliards de mesures d'urgence
c'est ça faire les secteurs encore en
difficulté l'hôtellerie la restauration
vous l'avez dit le tourisme aussi est-ce
que je suis très clair ce sont des
mesures uniquement pour les entreprises
dans ce budget il y aura aussi des
mesures pour les particuliers dans ces
15 milliards d'euros 2 millions
d'urgence il ya trois grandes trois
grands chapitres ou le remboursement des
exonérations de cotisations
remboursement par l'état est sécurité
sociale il ya le financement du fonds de
solidarité qui permet aux entreprises de
maintenir leur activité de maintenir de
se maintenir en attendant la sortie de
crise et il ya le financement de
l'activité partielle l'activité
partielle elle est souvent vue comme une
mesure en faveur des entreprises
ce avant tout de mesures en faveur des
salariés c'est cette activité parce
qu'elle finançait un niveau extrêmement
important qui permet de faire face et de
maintenir les emplois de maintenir les
compétences et de maintenir le pouvoir
d'achat il faut avoir en tête quand en
2020 nous avons connu une récession
absolument historique avec une perte de
croissance une croissance négative de 2
8% et dans le même temps le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages français a tenu
il a légèrement augmenté de 0,4 pour
cent y compris ce que nous avons baissé
les impôts
je pense à la taxe d'habitation ou à
l'impôt sur le revenu sur la première et
la seconde tranche est donc c'est avant
tout de mesures pour les ménages il ya
d'autres mesures dans ce budget que nous
finançons des engagements qui ont été
pris par le gouvernement par le
président de la république
je pense par exemple au passeport que le
président de la république a annoncé
pour permettre aux familles de finance
et de cofinancer l'adhésion la licence
dans un club sportif nous mettons une
centaine de millions d'euros à
disposition du ministère des sports pour
le mettre en oeuvre
je pense qu'ils sont l'hébergement
d'urgence nous avons fait le choix de ne
pas revenir à l'étiage habituellement
connue en période estivale en matière
d'hébergement d'urgence et de rester sur
un niveau non seulement hivernal mais
renforcé avec les 40000 places créées à
l'occasion de la crise qu vide
donc nous faisons face avec un budget
qui par ailleurs porte aussi des menus
des mesures pour les ménages portent
soit par le plf seule paire belle fss
des droits nouveaux donc nous faisons
face à cette crise là et nous essayons
avec ce plfr d'apporter les crédits
nécessaires pour permettre à l'économie
donc aux français de sortir de ce tunnel
nous nous espérons que le bout du tunnel
soit là évidemment sous réserve qu'elle
suit sont faits une terre continue à
s'améliorer mais c'est un espoir partagé
voyez comment la mairie nationale dont
nous espérons qu'ils soient le plus
rapide possible
je dis parfois que c'est tentant de
donner une date c'est aussi imprudent et
et donc il faut être extrêmement
attentif et le bout du tunnel il
marquera la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
le bout du tunnel doit marquer la fin de
quoi qu'il en coûte mais je lui dis de
manière très progressive
nous n'allons pas lâcher les entreprises
nous n'allons pas gâcher les efforts
faits par et finances publiques --dont
par les français depuis mars 2020 pour
quelques semaines ou quelques mois
ça serait dommage d'avoir soutenu
l'économie comme nous l'avons fait et de
ne pas le faire jusqu'au bout pour
quelques jours ou quelques semaines oui
vis-à-vis des veaux crains s'il faudra
cliquer des des réformes je pense
notamment à relancer une réforme de
financement des retraites sans être le
big bang qui était annoncé ce n'est pas
vis-à-vis d'aidé financier continuer les
réformes c'est vital et de la
soutenabilité de nos finances publiques
il y à la question des retraites
nous sommes nombreux à le dire les
abeilles borde le rappelait hier cette
réforme dans son esprit reste essentiel
le système actuel est illisible avec une
quarantaine de régime particulier avec
une pénalisation des carrières hachées
avec une pénalisation pour ceux qui font
des carrières partagé entre le public et
le privé
et par ailleurs il n'est pas soutenable
financièrement et la crise a encore
aggravé le déficit prévisionnel sacem de
l'avenir cette année le petit réforme
laisse c'est le président de la
république qui le décidera et qu'il est
tranchera c'est une réponse je crois que
vous avez entendu à plusieurs reprises
mais il n'ya pas que la réforme des
retraites il ya d'autres chantiers qui
sont ouverts nous devons par exemple
pardon parce que c'est un peu technique
mais et réorganiser la fonction la
politique d'achat de l'état et de ses
opérateurs
nous devons à améliorer le versement
d'un sprint de prestations c'est à dire
garder les mêmes droits voir les
améliorer mais avec des systèmes qui
permettent de prendre en compte la
réalité des revenus parce qu'on appelle
la contemporanéité ation des revenus
autant de chantiers qui sont ouverts et
puis dans les prochaines semaines
l'assemblée nationale aura l'occasion de
se saisir d'une proposition de loi 2
proposition de loi une portée par
laurent saint martin eric woerth et
l'autre porté par thomas meynier pour la
commission des finances et la commission
des affaires sociales avec une réforme
de la gouvernance des finances publiques
de la manière dont est à bord le budget
la manière dont on trace des
perspectives sur plusieurs années pour
avoir plus de lisibilité plus de
maîtrise
c'est à dire un budget pluriannuel pour
être clair nous avons déjà des lois de
programmation pluriannuelle mais avec la
volonté de renforcer cet aspect
programme hâtif de manière à avoir une
vraie maîtrise une vraie lisibilité
puisqu'on est dans le dans les questions
de remboursement on connaît votre
position sur la réforme des retraites
vous nous l'avez rappelé est ce que
l'augmentation du temps de travail c'est
une piste qui est envisageable
nous avons beaucoup beaucoup fait une
les différents gouvernements à la fois
pour protéger les 35 heures et permettre
à celles et ceux qui le souhaitent ou
qui en ont besoin de travailler un peu
plus c'est le cas avec l'exonération
fiscalité sur les heures supplémentaires
ça a été décidée sous nicolas sarkozy
remise en cause par françois hollande et
je considère en tout temps prendre ma
part de responsabilité c'était une
décision qu'il ya des marques et le
divorce entre les classes moyennes et la
gauche de gouvernement au début du
quinquennat de françois hollande
nous l'avons permis il ya des accords
pluriannuels sur le temps de travail qui
sont autorisés il ya toutes les
possibilités qui existent pour permettre
aux entreprises qui en ont besoin et aux
salariés qui le souhaitent de travailler
un peu plus que les 35 heures de manière
tout à fait enquête et je crois que il
ya un certain nombre de réformes de
qu'on qualifie parfois de totémique qui
peuvent parfois être inutile donc les
possibilités
les marges de manoeuvre sont largement
sur la fonction publique puisque c'est
un domaine que vous connaissez bien
est-ce que le la baisse du nombre de
fonctionnaires c'est enterré il n'y aura
pas de belles nous avons actionné
nous avons fait un certain nombre de
réductions d'effectifs dans la fonction
publique d'état au début du quinquennat
la crise et un vent d'ouest ont mis par
emmanuelle bercot moins que prévu
effectivement la décision incertaine une
décision prise je pense par exemple au
maintien des classes et des écoles dans
les zones rurales que le président de la
république avait annoncé à l'occasion du
grand débat national
la crise que nous avons connue avec la
nécessité par exemple d'augmenter les
effectifs de pôle emploi pour faire
phase face aux conséquences économiques
et sociales de la crise tout cela nous
amène aujourd'hui à aviser en 2021
comment 2022 une stabilité des emplois
de l'état c'est ce à quoi nous nous
sommes engagés dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2021 et c'est ce que nous
respecterons de l'habilité pour la
fonction publique d'état
pour la fonction publique territoriale
qu'est ce que la vôtre la fonction
publique territoriale est à la main des
collectivités
je sais que lorsque les collectivités
locales réalisent des économies sur
leurs dépenses de fonctionnement ça se
traduit souvent par des
non-remplacements de départs à la
retraite
il ya par ailleurs une loi que je
connais bien celle de transformation de
la fonction publique qui s'applique et
qui oblige d'une certaine manière les
collectivités locales a délibéré sur le
temps de travail de leurs agents dans
l'année qui suit l'élection c'est le cas
pour les communes et les
intercommunalités jusqu à la fin du mois
de juin dans un certain nombre de
communes dans son but intercommunalités
le temps de travail est inférieure aux
35 heures et donc les nouveaux accords
doivent permettre de travailler c'est 35
heures guillaume pelletier lierre et
disait qu'il fallait mettre fin à
l'emploi à vie dans la fonction publique
territoriale est ce que pour eux c'est
une bonne chose juge croit guillaume
pepy a dit beaucoup de bêtises hier et
ce n'est peut-être pas la plus grave qu
il dit au cours de l'interview qu'il a
donnée à l'emploi à vie c'est l'emploi
du statut et je le dis en sachant
pertinemment que le statut n'est pas une
protection absolue et que vous pouvez
être radié des cadres de la fonction
publique la loi que j'ai évoquées donne
là aussi beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
dont les employeurs publics tous
confondus tous confondus peuvent se
saisir sur le recours à des contractuels
et des contrats longs sur le recours à
des cdd contrats à durée indéterminée et
le recours à des contrats de projet
cette fois je la défends et amélie deux
manches à la lame et en oeuvre
aujourd'hui avec beaucoup de talent on
s'éloigne
l'emploi c'est une loi qui apporte à nos
droits elle a apporté des droits
contractuels
un exemple depuis le 1er janvier 2021
dans le secteur public les contrats
courent les cdd courts demain en moins
d'un an sont accompagnés d'une prime de
précarité comme c'était dans le privé
depuis très longtemps
parfois il réforme de la fonction
publique permettent par un alignement
des droits de renforcer les droits des
agents publics et c'est bien comme ça
dernière question sur ce remboursement
de la dette est ce qu il faut qu on
s'inquiète pour notre épargne
je ne crois pas il faut là il part
nicolas mobilisés au contraire il faut
un wc comment on fait pour sauver les
français à la dépense et sur la
confiance
il ya eu 4 116 milliards d'épargné c'est
par la confiance dès lors que la
croissance économique est là dès lors
que la vie peut reprendre libérer des
contraintes sanitaires
je suis convaincu que les français vont
se rattraper tant pour la consommation
que pour leurrer les autres l'arize
elles n'ont pas tiré tout l'argent du
1er juin dépassait plus sur la relance
parce que sur le l'épargnent pas ce que
vous dites je ne crois pas est-ce que
vous misez sur une confiance des
français comme vient de le dire pascal
mais est-ce que vous allez taxer
l'épargné à un moment pour transposer la
marque de fabrique de ce gouvernement
c'est de refuser l'augmentation de la
fiscalité c'est même de baisser la
fiscalité
donc les femmes ne st pas dans l'axé
c'est pas par la cma voulons pas payer
d'impôts et nous ne voulons pas
augmenter les impôts
entre le début et la fin du quinquennat
les impôts ont baissé de 50 milliards
d'euros 25 pour les ménages et 25 pour
les entreprises
et c'est sur cette ligne nous voulons
continuer oui les entreprises n'ont pas
tiré tout l'argent du premier plan de
relance
comment mieux les inciter à le faire
maintenant et faut-il un vrai second
plan à à l'heure où nous parlons il ya
plus 36 milliards d'euros qui sont
engagés sur les 100 milliards et donc
nous tenons nos objectifs l'objectif que
nous nous sommes fixés avec bono le
maire et que la moitié des plans de
relance soient décaissés
à la fin de l'année 2021 pour qu'en 2022
le solde viennent et que le temps de
relance soient mise en oeuvre il y a
presque un tiers des entreprises
industrielles qui vont être accompagnés
il y a des centaines de milliers
d'apprentis qui ont été recrutés grâce
aux aides que nous avons mise en oeuvre
des centaines de milliers de jeunes de
moins de 26 ans
je me déplace dans tous les départements
j'en ai visité 35 en l'espace de
quelques semaines et je peux vous
assurer que le temps de relancer et bien
mise en oeuvre on vous dit
et ce n'est pas été suffisamment
mobilisée et pourtant sur l'aide à
l'industrie des dispositifs qu'on
appelle industries du futur territoire
d'industrie numérisation des pme les
appels à manifestation d'intérêt les
appels à projets sont déjà épuisés et à
l'occasion
modification du plfr que j'aurais a
présenté mercredi au conseil des
ministres nous rechargeons ce dispositif
à hauteur d'un milliard d'euros en
partenariat souvent avec les régions pro
territoire d'industrie parce qu'il a
plus de demandes qu'il n'y avait de
crédit c'est plutôt bon signe et ça
montre que les entreprises se sont
saisis les pensait d'ailleurs que c'est
2022 qui va être à la vraie lancé 2021
et 2022
la commission européenne dit que nous
aurons une croissance de tous les pays
de la zone euro la plus forte en 2021 à
plus de 5% donc elle est plus optimiste
que que nos sein du gouvernement et que
nous aurons aussi la croissance la plus
forte
ap 8 4% en 2022 tout ça est portée à la
fois par la confiance des chefs
d'entreprise elle s'exprime dans
différentes études et par la mise en
oeuvre du plan de relance qui marche
bien qu'ils avancent bien au cours de
l'été nous présenter république l'a dit
nous allons faire un point un bilan nous
allons regarder là où il serait
nécessaire de soutenir les
investissements peut être à plus long
terme
comment est-ce qu'on l'ait financé par
l'état par la mobilisation de thèmes
tels financements bancaires
est-ce que c'est par l'union européenne
pour construire des filières l échelle
européenne
tout ça nous allons faire dans les tons
qui viennent mais nous aurons une
priorité absolue c'est faire en sorte
que le plan de relance de 100 milliards
d'euros sont engagés et nous y veillons
quotidienne et justement puisqu'on parle
du plan de relance et 27 états membres
ont approuvé jeudi soir ça y est le plan
de relance européen quand la france
verra t elle les quarantenaires il
désormais l'union européenne a le droit
de mobiliser les marchés pour financer
son plan de relance de 550 milliards
d'euros dont 390 de subventions aux
états le premier acompte pour la france
devrait intervenir au mois de septembre
comme nous l'avons dit lors de la
présentation du programme des invités à
hauteur de 5 milliards cent si cette
avance et c'est très bien et c'est tant
mieux mais nous avons prévu septembre
par prudence évidemment si ça peut aller
plus vite nous serons très satisfaits
mais ça peut être des salles il était à
la fin à la fin de l'année nous on nous
dirons à la commission européenne quels
sont les éléments du plan de relance que
nous avons engagées pour demander un
deuxième versement
l'objectif est effectivement la france
d'ici 2023 2024
c'est toujours avec un petit temps de
décalage puisse percevoir 40 milliards
d'euros de ce plan ça sera combien le
versement de satan l'acompte tel qu'il
est prévu dans l'accord et à s'en tenir
sans on va parler des dépenses de santé
puisqu'il faut des moyens beaucoup de
dépenses de santé liées aux qu'ovide 1
dépenses de santé à proprement parler
les masques les tests les vaccins à
combien vous les chiffres et aujourd'hui
c'est des pourris nous avons prévu que
le projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale engage 4 milliards cinq
pour faire face aux dépenses du comité
nous savons ça sera plus important
puisque beaucoup plus important parce
que devant la commission des affaires
sociales de l'assemblée nationale du
directeur de la sécurité sociale il
évoque un surcoût de 9 à 10 milliards
par rapport aux 4 hier que vous êtes
c'est exactement cela
c'est exactement cela il ya un surcoût
lié au fait que les hôpitaux sont très
mobilisés et que nous continuons à les
accompagner et renforcer leurs moyens
il ya un coût lié à la campagne de
vaccination est un coup les alliés à la
campagne de tests lorsque le projet loi
de finances de sécurité sociale ajis
ckoi 14 milliards très ému donc on n'est
pas loin mais lorsque le projet de
financement de la sécurité sociale a été
examiné par l'assemblée et par le sénat
nous ne connaissions pas à ce moment là
il ya date de disponibilité des vaccins
ni leurs coûts le coût de la campagne de
vaccination s'est un peu plus de 5
milliards d'euros le coût de la campagne
de tests les tests pcr qui sont gratuits
en france et au danemark et nulle part
ailleurs gratuit pour tous nous sommes
les deux seuls pays à faire la gratuité
totale
ces 5 milliards d'euros 6 donc
évidemment il y à un surcoût et sur coup
nous avons l'occasion de le dire devant
la commission des finances à l'assemblée
le directeur de l'esc de la sécurité
sociale a aussi rappelé vous allez
rembourser les collectivités locales qui
ont engagé beaucoup d'argent pour la
vaccination ou alors de le faire du cas
par cas les d'abord le miz la santé a
indiqué que au niveau des rs il y avait
des fonds disponibles pour financer
cofinancer les centres de vaccination
donc il s'engage manqué prix et le
ministère de la santé le tiendra il faut
par ailleurs dire que les collectivités
locales sont des acteurs l'action
publique qui ont été extrêmement bien
protéger d'abord leurs impôts beaucoup
moins baissé que prévu et gestion de
nous alerter les nations libres et du
soft est bon le voir quand le
remboursement de la dette et des frais
engagés meilleure santé a indiqué que
plus de 120 millions d'euros est à
disposition des ars je ne connais pas le
calendrier de remboursement
mais il ne faut pas s'arrêter à la seule
question de la vaccination
je répète dans le cadre des mesures
d'urgence et du plan de relance sont
presque 10 milliards d'euros qui sont
engagés pour les collectivités pour
garantir leur recette c'est la première
fois que nous avons garanti un niveau
minimum de recettes fiscales et
domaniale pour les accompagner sur rome
entre l'été 2009 et l'été 2021 en plus
des mesures classiques de soutien
d'investissement nous
nous avons ajouté deux milliards de dhs
est-il la dotation soutien à
l'investissement local soit pour la
relance soit pour la rénovation
thermique
je pourrais citer les aides aux
autorités organisatrices de mobilité et
l'ensemble des projets de collectivités
soutenu par l'état les collectivités ont
vu leur situation se dégrader en 2020
beaucoup moins que celle de l'état et la
sécurité sociale dans en moyenne de
manière très générale elles ont un
compte de deux un compte de résultat qui
est à l' équilibre
la houle et a vu sa situation se
dégrader de plusieurs dizaines de
milliards dont on va parler politique
pour terminer nous reste peu de temps à
parler des régionales puisque finalement
les discussions de la majorité avec les
présidents sortants et se sont limités à
renaud muselier et à la région sud elles
se sont limités à un barrage au front
national
est-ce que vous l'homme de gauche pour
regretter qu'il n'ai pas eu de
discussions formelles avec des
présidences d'un certain nombre de
présidents de gauche sortants ou
présidente n'ont pas souhaité ces
discussions nous devrons au soir du
premier tour quelle est la configuration
un second c'est en bourgogne franche
comté par exemple où il va faire bisquer
rennes
il faudra faire barrage au front
national et je souhaite que denis curio
le candidat de la majorité issus de la
gauche je le rappelle mais qui a su
dépasser qui a su rassembler qui a su
être dans un dépassement au niveau
régional je souhaite qu'il soit en tête
et je souhaite qu'au second tour toutes
les forces politiques et notamment
effort social démocrate se rassemble
derrière lui s'il est en tête de la même
manière que si d'autres candidats et si
la présidente sortante était mieux placé
nous serons aussi prendre nos
responsabilités ça veut dire la soutenir
marine la soutenir mais je pense que d
une torrio fait une très bonne campagne
et est ce que quand même c'est pas
révélateur le fait que finalement il ya
désaccord plus avec la droite et
quasiment aucun aucun d'ailleurs avec la
gauche est ce que c'est quand même pas
révélateur d'une majorité qui penche
clairement à droite est-ce que ça ça les
rend les mâles cas et c'est une
ritournelle que les uns et les autres
vous engueuler quand je vous engagez
vous répétez actuelle ce n'est pas
absolument pas factuel nous avons fait
barrage au front national dans la région
sud est ce qui compte pour moi dans la
politique c'est ce que nous faisons
c'est moi j'ai été engagé au parti
socialiste pendant 20 ans je n'ai aucun
regret et j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs
j'ai souvenir qu'à chaque réunion de
section on disait que le jour où on aura
une vraie sécurité sociale c'est parce
que les prothèses dentaires les
prothèses auditives les lunettes
pourraient être à la portée de tout le
monde
nous avons fait le reste à charge 0 il
se met en place
c'est le souvenir de discussions avec
des syndicalistes ce retraité notamment
la cfdt mais pas seulement qu'ils aient
le jour où on sera vraiment costaud en
matière de protection c'est quand on
aura créer une cinquième branche pour
financer l'autonomie la dépendance est
fait ce que nous avons fait dans le
domaine de l'éducation et des
dédoublements
c'est ce que la gauche aurait dû faire
depuis longtemps et donc ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le fond ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la capacité à
rassembler c'est celle que le président
la république porte aujourd'hui ce qui
m'intéresse aussi
c'est le second tour l'adn de la
majorité c'est faire barrage à l'extrême
droite et je pense que dans un certain
nombre de régions les sites et la
bourgogne
on prépare ce penser à la bretagne même
si le risque fn est un peu moins
important il faudra qu'il y ait des
rassemblements dans tout ça c'est que
des régions de gauche
vous êtes près aussi posé la question
ces acquis sont vos promesses vous vous
soutenez c'est à dire que on a entendu
un peu l'ailé gauche de la majorité qui
n'était pas forcément content de cet
accord avec renaud muselier
c'est toujours compliqué pour des
militants qui ont construit leur
engagement dans une opposition un
personnel politique autour de renaud
muselier autres christian estrosi de
franchir le cap et sa mesure ça laisse
mesurer combien cette décision est
difficile par salem de soutenir un
président droite s'il ya un risque est
reine dans une région où il nous avons
toujours fait et de la même manière que
j'attendais hommes deux femmes des
hommes et des femmes de droite comme de
gauche qui soutiennent la majorité
lorsqu'il ya un risque front national et
que me sens mieux placé pour l'emporter
merci beaucoup merci au lit les disques
d'avoir était notre invité ce matin là
une des dernières nouvelles d'alsace
pascal et deux des journaux du groupe
ebra d'ailleurs les régionales oui les
régionales avec dombes à ces régions qui
ont du mal à se frayer une place sur la
carte de france par rapport aux
départements et aux communes que
citoyens sentent plus proches d'où entre
guillemets la nationalisation de ce
scrutin
et merci beaucoup merci au lycée
[Musique]